the Pope was in st. Peter's Square a
couple days ago and he might have just
given an exorcism in front of everybody
let's take a look
okay so it's a it's a little unclear to
me whether the music was actually
playing at that one Count Dracula
alright so there's so many ways we can
go with this so first off because I know
you're both exorcism specialists would
you say that that was an exorcism Jen
I've had it in way wilder than that no
no you can't tell I mean look this is
the one thing I will say about faith
healing type things when you're a family
and you have someone who's ill and
you're desperate sometimes a little
faith can go a long way emotionally for
you so for me it doesn't look like you
did anything like violent unacceptable
anything that was hurting this person so
to me it's like I don't really give a
[ __ ] if it's an exorcism if it made the
family feel a little bit better right
now Cara I know you're not big on
religion to say the least
I'm not a believer I'm an atheist so
what me like I don't see the difference
maybe that's a prayer or an exorcism
they're both equally same thing to me
it's all the faith healing is all the
same to me whether he was like I bless
you my son you're now absolved you're
gonna get up and walk and run marathons
or he shook his head around and did an
exercise the same thing to you okay so
for someone though that crazy for
someone though that is an atheist if
what he did even if it didn't have any
tangible like real spiritual thing going
on but if the person who was there the
handicapped person was healed by it
somehow even if they just tricked
themselves does that seem like a good
thing to you then happen that's not what
happened that's not going you don't
think that person is gonna be any better
if that person has like MS or cerebral
palsy or you know some some legitimate
biological ailment that's putting them
in that wheelchair
trust me the Pope did not just do that
that's not even like worth I think
you're responding to I just don't it
that would be a miracle you know what I
mean and miracles don't happen not not
in the spiritual sense but but like I
said I think that the idea of whether
it's a prayer or an exorcism it's all
the same and truth be told in Catholic
dogma I mean the Pope is a priest right
or he's a what do you call 100 God yeah
and they all they all have a power to
perform
yes and I think this Pope specifically
has performed exorcisms before so it's
not really that surprising right so why
do you think the church like immediately
they were like no no was it an exorcism
and you know dude why do they feel like
me eating followers and the word
exorcism is very intense I think first
of all and second of all I think that if
you I think that's a problem where a lot
of people now will base you know faith
healing instead of getting medical
treatment like what you were saying if
he has cerebral palsy PSMs if he's not
seeking actual treatment or doesn't have
the money or means to get that and is
relying on the church to cure him I
think that could freak people out and
people could attack the church saying
you're replacing actual means and health
and real you know medical procedures
with that I think that's why they back
away I also think they're trying to be
more modern as a religion I think this
Pope is viewed as a more progressive
more modern Pope and when you do they
say that about every toe this guy's
going we think the word exorcism we
think of like the Middle Ages I just
don't think that it's good PR for them
if they do come out and say this was a
you know on-the-fly exorcism that he
just perform right in public yeah we're
gonna talk a little bit more about
religion later but does this show you
like why religion in the modern day sort
of is just kind of bonkers because even
something even something just a quiet
reaching to the to this preached already
I guess but because that perhaps if they
believe something good is about this
they can't even say it and that's kind
of bizarre isn't it I mean I think if
you're if you do think something's great
about it and they think this was a good
thing for their church and this is
something they do regularly then stand
up and say it'd be like we're gonna be
doing exorcisms y'all like just come on
down come and get it you know y'all I
know why you think that's what I think
of I always think of those when they
have the huge churches and people are
coming up the steps and they're doing
the faith healing or that exactly so
what is that okay so as yeah right no no
but I mean what is it actually like in
the in the human is that this need to be
connected to sighing so badly that even
if it's not real it's the same thing as
hypnotism which there is evidence to
show that people can be hypnotized but
it's all about susceptibility it's all
about wanting it bad enough and and kind
of finding yourself in that headspace
and so people who speak in tongues I
think they do truly believe that there's
some sort of I don't know if it's
supposed to be positive or negative but
some sort of spirit running through them
that is possessing them and allowing
them to do that
we know objectively that that's not
what's happening but it's not like these
people are always charlatans I think a
lot of them actually think that it's
occurring have you ever just been like
really sick or something bad has
happened you've found yourself being
like please God done it even if you
don't believe in God or you're not
religious you just cuz I'm not I'm
pretty much agnostic atheist I walk that
line I have faith in something larger
than me but I certainly don't I don't
believe in God as prescribed judging you
certainly don't believe in any organized
religion nor do I think it's healthy for
people I think it's a crutch and almost
like a mental illness bla bla bla but
that being said I do think that
sometimes when you're just in need and
weak you know and I hate to say the ex
people wanna go no religion makes me
strong but a lot of the time it is when
you need faith whether it's a specific
religion or whether it's just some sort
of universal universe please help me
you'll find yourself just going oh
please let this happen or please protect
me and I think that's when you get the
most desperate people because if you're
a person in a wheelchair not walking
that's when you're gonna be looking
towards a faith healing or an exorcism
because you're you're desperate and
you're sad and you're hurting and you're
in pain and so is your family
I think that's common I mean I don't
think that personally applies to me
because atheism is a big part of like my
kind of cultural identity so you know
when they say there are no atheists in
foxholes like trust me I'd be an atheist
in a foxhole like that you'd still hold
on to it at that oh yeah I've never like
asked God like oh I left the church I've
never asked a God for anything I've
never kind of found myself on my knees
that's not to say I wouldn't if for some
reason there was real evidence to be
ever but that's not gonna happen but
you're right I do think that it's the
same it's this whether it's religious or
whether it's kind of last-ditch kind of
medical not legitimate medicine you know
alternative men there are and sometimes
these are these are very negative
because there are people who will take
advantage of people when they're very
sick and very weak but when all of your
options are
extinguished it can have something of a
placebo effect yeah well to put a cap on
this most of the things I learned about
religion and God and science was from
watching the movie contact after eating
pop rounds so okay